Hello, my name is
Aluga, D.O. I'm a
pathologist at Arkansas
State University,
New York Institute
of Technology.
There's my office,
phone number,
email, so feel free to
contact me if you
have questions.
There's a survey
at the end, you
can email me or
any questions.
This is going to
be the pathology
of cerebrovascular
diseases discussion
today, and here's
our objectives,
and I highlighted
what they were,
obviously pathology,
ischemic ******,
hemorrhagic ******,
transient ischemic,
brain trauma,
so anything dealing
with blood vessels
and blood and loss
of oxygen, loss
of blood flow,
loss of perfusion.
There's a lot of
changes in ischemic
infarctions,
classifications of those
strokes, different
kinds of ischemia
that can occur
through thrombosis,
emboli, or global
hyperperfusion.
Hemorrhagic strokes,
those are going to
be looking a little
different. And what's
associated with
those, hypertension
or something called
amyloid angiopathy,
subarachnoid
hemorrhage, and
what kind of
hemorrhage that leads
to, intercerebral
hemorrhage.
And then there's
subarachnoid hemorrhage
associated with
traumatic, aneurysmal, and
what's called arterial
venous malformations.
So what can happen
with trauma?
We're going to talk
about herniations,
skull fractures,
concussion, surgery,
and epidural hematomas.
still dealing
with trauma, we're
going to talk about
contusions and coo
-contra-coo injuries
and something
called diffuse
axonal injury, okay?
So this isn't one of
the disorders that
we're going to be
discussing. This is just
something good to know
because it's used a
lot, I mean, used a lot
of imaging when you're
looking at the
cerebrovascular diseases.
There's something
called the Hounsfield
unit used with CT
and a non-contrast CT
is going to be a common
test that's going
to be done with someone
with a head trauma
or some other
abnormality of the CNS
due to possible
cerebrovascular disorder.
So Hounsfield unit,
and here's a chart
here, and I guess Mr.
Hounsfield, Dr. Hounsfield
made up this chart
a long time ago.
And so less dense,
so water has a,
is set as zero hounds
field units okay so
water is going to
blood as a water where
is it here water is
zero ones that are
positive are going to
appear bright okay for
example hemorrhage gray
matter so hemorrhage
is a little brighter
than gray matter
you can see here so it's
a little it's bright
but it's a little gray
it's not dark like
the fluid in the
ventricles of CSF muscle
about the same white
matter about the
same but bone that's
going to be very bright
okay so very dense so
hemorrhage and bony
structure high positive
Hounsworth units.
Blood is a high
Hounsworth unit number
because of a lot of
protein and iron in it,
in that material.
Less dense ones like
fat are going to appear
dark. Okay, so you can
see the white matter,
that appears darker
than the gray matter.
Okay,
and then
so it's going to be
negative, and then air,
that's going to be
very negative, okay,
and appear dark.
Here is how it
might appear, and so
you can use your
Hounsfield units to
see what you might
think this would
be, so this is an
acute hemorrhage,
so it's hyperdense
and bright,
so a lot of positive
hounds field units
there so maybe thinking
it's blood but then
it's starting to
consolidate and my creatures
are coming in and
starting to clean this
up so it becomes more
I mean less bright
so it may be isodense
with the surrounding
CMS then it becomes
hypodense as you know
that's you know starts
to resolve later and
it becomes cystic you
know because there
could be some cystic
degeneration of portions
of the brain and
also this mass tube
might start
disintegrating, dissolving,
because of the macrophages
and other enzymes.
Cerebrovascular disease
are common in the
United States of
America and they include
all disorders that
involve any part of the
brain with temporary,
or that is temporarily
or permanently
affected by ischemia
or bleeding.
So the things that
blood vessels do,
that's all disorders
that could possibly
be associated with
those processes.
And one or more cerebral
vessels are involved.
Here's a diagram
that shows several
cerebral vessels here
to the right. and
different disorders
that might occur from
rupture and hemorrhage
to thrombosis to
looks like atherosclerotic
plaque here
and then maybe an
emboli came and
launched right there
so those would cause
the processes that
we just mentioned all
right so i wrote
aka ****** so when
a part of the brain
temporarily or
permanently affected
by ischemia or
bleeding that's also
known as ******,
so brain blood flow
suddenly reduced,
so cells become
hypoxic due to
hypoxemia, low blood
O2, or ischemia,
low blood flow,
which you want
to have the oxygen
that supplies.
That can cause cell
disability and possible
infarction, which is
necrosis, cell death.
so when blood flow is
reduced by any process
survival depends
on what's called
collateral circulation
so the connections with
other blood vessels
for that territory that
that blood was supplying
okay how how long
that loss of blood
flow and oxygen is
lasting how great the
drop in blood flow was
was it maximum you
know what normal was
to nothing all at once
and how rapidly that
reduction occurs a
lot of the collateral
circulation for the
CNS comes out of this
circle of Willis with
his various branches
but also external
carotid ophthalmic artery
collaterals there's
little if any for
those really deep
structures like the thalamus
basal ganglia and
deep white matter
collateral flow so they
can suffer from like
global hyper hyper
perfusion of the brain
because of the lack of
that collateral flow
different types of
strokes looks like I
left a bullet point
out of this up of this
one so strokes are also
called cerebrovascular
accidents or CBAs
the different types
are ischemic or
hemorrhagic 87% so the
vast majority are going
to be ischemic where
you have loss of
perfusion to a territory
of the brain that
vessel was applying.
Bloxychloroquine
vein may be like
maybe superior
saturated sinus
in the brain or,
but that's rare.
Storm cell, a lack of
fusion, hemorrhagic
strokes,
13% are caused by
a bleeding artery.
Okay, so as you can
see, blood is going to
extravasate and it's
going to be reabsorbed.
But because this blood
is going into the
tissues, it's not
supplying the cells
that the capillary
beds were supposed to
supply oxygen and
remove carbon dioxide
from those cells so
the tissue surrounding
in this area is
going to become
hypoxic okay and also
because it's an expanding
mass you know it's
going to become
a hematoma that's going
to cause compression
and necrosis and
the adjacent bone
CNS structures.
The transition region
and we'll say this
gray area is going to
be then the carotid
tissue this tissue is
deceased and normal brain
tissue you know this
tissue out here so
just around the edges
to variable degrees
depending on you know
like claterals things
like that is going to
be an area that's at
risk okay so this area
may not be functioning
properly because it
has reduced levels
of oxygen but it can
recover as long as it
gets its perfusion back
that's known as the
penumbra and that can
be rescued so you and
that's what you want
to do so you want to
do that as quickly as
possible so you can
preserve as much CNS
tissue as possible so
you can use anti
apoptotic interventions,
so medicines to prevent
this, and that suggests
that ischemic neurons
die by apoptosis
and necrosis. So that
was kind of an experiment
someone did to see
if there's apoptosis
going on there, and
apparently there is.
So different etiologies,
and this is going
to be the ischemic type
******, where there's
going to be a loss
of blood flow. Okay,
so here's two different
examples of what's
called a thrombotic
******, and one of the
simplest one to
understand, most common, is
going to be atherosclerotic
plaques. They're
going to cause a
narrowing here, and
these plaque surfaces,
they're fragile, and if
there's like fast flow
or something happens
and that ruptures
that plaque, then that
could form a thrombus
and block that flow.
So, lipohylinosis
is another one. It's
associated with,
see, this is going
towards these
larger vessels. So,
you see like the
middle cerebral, middle
meningeal artery
here is affected.
And here is these
smaller deep penetrating
arteries, okay, that
are going to be affected
by, in this case,
usually hypertension,
okay. And that's
going to cause
the lumen to be
thinned as well,
okay. So, and that's
also going to damage
the vessel wall and
make that susceptible
to reactive oxygen
species and injury
from high flow and
a thrombus may form.
Okay, so thrombotic
atherosclerosis, we
already went over
that. Lipohyanosis,
we went over that.
Then there's embolic.
Okay, so here's
an embolus. It
can come from
various locations.
if it's in the arterial
system it could
come from the heart
you could have atrial
fibrillation a piece
could break off and then
travel into your CNS
circulation and lodge
at the narrowest part
that it can reach
and so I mentioned
cardiogenic then
there's non-cardiogenic
and that's usually
from things like
atherosclerotic plaque
so this could be
say for example the
common carotid artery
and then a portion
could break off
and then go through
the CNS circulation
and once again reach
a narrow point and
block that area.
So it's going to
usually, non-cardiogenic
is going to be
atherosclerotic
plaques in the internal
carotid artery.
The middle
cerebral artery
characteristic
most frequently
is one most frequently
affected by M-malli.
And those tend to
lodge in an eventual
branch with a pre
-existing stenosis.
So like I said,
when it reaches the
narrow point,
it's going to get
lodged there and
it's going to stop.
Okay.
Other,
see I didn't highlight
any of this down
here, but these are
other things you
may have been wondering
about. Yeah, if
it gets inflamed,
vasculitis can cause
luminal narrowing
and occlusion. For
example, polyarteritis
nodosa, drug *****
may cause vascular
spasm, like *******,
opioids, and
even occlusion.
Aneurysm, AVMs, and
coagulopathy, they
can all cause
thrombosis, and of
course you get thronged
by developing an
aneurysm, but they
can rupture too.
Vascular malformations
steal blood from
surrounding tissue
and they become
hypoxic, and they
may rupture as well.
There's something
called global ischemia,
where these processes
aren't occurring, but
the person becomes
severely hypotensive.
And when that occurs,
there's areas called
border zones or
watershed zones. And a
watershed is a basin where
water drains to, okay?
That's what a watershed
is. So it's a region
where things are
flowing towards, okay?
so in the brain you
can think of it you
know kind of like that
so it's gonna be at
the junctions of two
major arteries territories
so between them they
may not reach each
other exactly so the
cells right between
them if there's a little
they may be getting
just as much oxygen
as they need but
if it drops just a
little bit they're gonna
be in trouble okay
maybe they'll start
going into some sort
of reversible injury
program and you know
start to get ballooning
degeneration and these
kind of things that
happen but that could
be reversible as long
as you increase the
perfusion pressure.
So these areas are
vulnerable to ischemia
and there's a slide
about that later.
So this is a
molecular path,
this is just
something about
something called
excitotoxicity.
That comes from this
molecule glutamate
and this molecule
can damage neurons by
allowing calcium ions
to influx because
it interacts with
this NMD8 receptor.
How does a lot
of glutamate
get into ischemic areas?
Well ischemia can
cause these amino acids
to be inappropriate
released from the
damaged cells and
then it's released
into the adjacent
surrounding structures.
So don't memorize this
this is just something
scientific to know
so here's an example
of an ischemic ******
this would be not
acute okay this be kind
of a resolving ******
this would be what
have happened a while
back because of its
because of how dark it
is compared to the
rest of the surrounding
serene cortex okay if
an artery becomes so
what happens ischemic
****** ischemic ******
there's occlusion of
an upstream artery
and again infarction
downstream infarction
because you get tissue
hypoxia then you and
then once you get
past reversible cell
injury, if the epoxy
persists long enough or is
reduced quickly enough,
then irreversible
neuronal injury, it
can be as fast as five
minutes after the
tissue becomes hypoxic.
If there's
sustained ischemia,
that can produce
infarction.
And what's called
liquefactive necrosis,
which you learned a
long time ago, which is
one of the characteristics
of CNS necrosis.
It's very sensitive
to the enzymes that
are released by cells
in that tissue when
they become necrotic
for digestion of
all its components,
all its lipids, all its
carbohydrates, all
its proteins, all of
that. And it turns it
into a liquid kind of
gelatinous, kind of
thick mass of cells.
Okay, so the hydrolytic
enzymes do that.
Those come from
inflammatory cells
and enzymes from the
tissues themselves
that are being
released. Over time
macrophages are
going to clear it and
they're going to be
left with a cystic
space. This doesn't
show cystic space.
It shows you got this
mass, it happened
a while back and
it's shifting the
midline so you see
this was one of the
ventricles but now
it's over on this
side, the left side
of the ball cerebrine
when it's supposed
to be over here.
So this is what
you see grossly,
little change
in the first six
hours of
irreversible injury.
This is grossly.
At about 48 hours it may
become pale,
soft swollen,
about two to ten
days gelatinous It's
probably 10 days to
weeks, it liquefies.
And this is just
another timeline,
these are the molecular
events you would
see, or the
microscopic events you
would see. So about
12 to 24 hours, you'll
start seeing the
cytoplasm, see this
neuron, which is
ischemic compared to
this neuron over
here, which is not,
this cytoplasm is darker,
pinker. maybe more
magenta color it's
darker more vibrant
and look at this nucleus
it's becoming very
dark compared to these
other ones you don't
even see that big
nucleolus anymore that is
indicative of a neuron
I see is a big dark
nucleus so when you
get these really dark
red neurons those
are indicating it's a
necrotic neuron, okay?
So about 12, 24 hours.
Because of that,
neutrophils are going
to come in, and
for the next couple
days, they're going
to respond to the
signals of this tissue
that is ischemic.
And after that,
after about three
days, they're going to
peak, and then they're
going to start to fall
off, and macrophages
are going to become
predominant cells along
with microglia and
they're going to go in
and phagocyte hose all
that dead tissue and
the astrocytes are
going to become more
active at about a week
and they need to
rebuild as much of the
architecture as they
can they are glial cells
so they're going to be
become a bit hypertrophic
cytoplasm is going
to become plop
they're going to have to
send out extensions so
they can guide neurons
around to where they
need to go to restore
as much function as
possible and get the
vasculature restored
as much as it can be
done and this is an
example of liquid
effectiveness process in a
photographic image
all this what you see
grossly here is going
to be the chronic
tissue and you see
the discolored area
right around the
edges that's probably
the penumbra, the
area at risk, okay.
So after this cystic
space has been removed
by macrophages and then
the glial cells come
in and try to repair
this and help get
neurons back in there
as much as they can,
you're going to get a
lot of reactive gliosis,
okay, so a lot of
these cells here,
there's going to be
some degenerating
neurons here but
you see a lot
of these little
cells, these are
oligodendrocytes and
these are going to
be your astrocytes. So
they have big nuclei
with big nucleoli,
a lot of cytoplasm,
so they're very
active trying to do as
much as they can to
remove the tissues
as best can be done.
And so when they're
done, they're going to
be left with a glial
scar, which will
show a lot of neuron
loss. There might
be some neurons that
can be restored, guided
into that region.
You're going to see
a lot of reactive
astrocytes there
still. You'll see a
bunch of fibroblasts
because they're
trying to hold the
tissue together and
endothelial cells
trying to revascularize
that tissue and
microglia because
those are the
macrophages of the brain.
So these are the
histologic changes.
Once again,
you know, I'm staying
on topic. acute
cerebral infarction so
this the vessel that was
causing the problem
you get marked edema
pale areas okay so
these cells have a lot
of extra fluid within
their cytoplasm right
now so they look pale
six to twenty four
hours you get once
again eosinophilic
neurons red dead neurons
you get that really
dark ignotic or cario
-rectic where it starts
to break up nucleus so
red neurons Neurons,
neutrophils, macrophages,
and the cystic
cavity are going to
be characteristic
features. Here's the
red neurons and you can
see how red they look
compared to, I can't
see any normal ones
here, but let's see,
yeah they didn't
include any of that,
they just took
a picture of
what area that
was necrotic,
okay. Okay,
so up to about four
to eight hours,
neutrophils
immigrate into that
area where you've
got necrosis,
but then it falls
off after that,
macrophages become
more prominent. So
they're going to be
lipid-laving because
you know the myelin
sheath is going
to be covered with
a lot of lipids.
And they're going
to be engulfing all
these damaged
structures and tissues
that liquefactor
necrosis has produced.
Okay, I'm trying to get
rid of that material.
And then glial cells
are going to come in
and they're going to be
around the edges where
this lucrofactor
necrosis is occurring and
that material is being,
you know, removed.
And they're going to,
as soon as much of
it can be removed,
they're going to come in
and try to repair it
as much as they can.
But you're
going to be left
with these cystic spaces.
So this is a thrombotic
ischemic ******. So,
commonly, they have
a plaque, commonly in
the internal carotid,
and that's going to
reduce blood flow,
okay, create turbulence
too. So, that's an
environment for plaque
rupture and thrombosis
to occur, most
commonly in this
internal carotid artery.
So, the most
common type of
******, thrombotic,
associated
with hypertension
and diabetes,
you know, they accelerate
atherosclerosis.
uh throngous uh
uh and you get
progressive luminal
narrow narrowing we've
commonly seen an older
person um okay um
and those with a lot
of uh high cholesterol
and atherosclerosis
um and i kind of
explained the process
already oh most
common at the carotid
bifurcation here,
the middle
cerebral artery
origin, so right
up here, and either
end of the
basilar artery.
No, they don't
really show it.
Okay.
Staying on the
thrombotic ischemic
****** and
atherosclerosis,
common sight, I already
mentioned these.
The common carotid,
though, bifurcation,
if you have a clot
that is going to be a
thrombotic ischemic
******, it's going to
travel up to the first,
well, this is talking
about NY. so part
of that thrombus can
break off okay so and
they can travel up to
the first intracranial
branch of the internal
carotid artery and
that's the ophthalmic
artery I mentioned
that because it's going
to find this narrowest
point and it's
going to get stuck
there and that vessel is
applying the territory
of the retina and
that's not going to
be functioning anymore
so that's what's called
amorosis fugax so
it's transient sextaminus
because these small
vessels So fibrinolysis
will be able to
take care of things
quickly and maybe get
rid of it for any
damage for small emboli.
So vision loss from
hyperperfusion,
retina, or the
optic nerve itself.
And that's another common
area I already mentioned.
So here's a CT angiogram.
It's showing what's called
the lenticulostriate
arteries. And that
thrombus, again,
right there at
the, looks like
the, I guess
it's bifurcation
of the middle
meningeal artery.
I think, okay,
that's where the most
common, you get that
atherosclerotic plaque
forming and that
thrombus forming, and
then you might get
some little bits
flying off that. Here's
a CT angiogram of
a ******, and you're
looking at these
lenticulostriate
arteries in this case.
And in this red circle,
this is an angiogram,
so there's a contrast
in these blood
vessels and you can see
some of the vessels with
the contrast in it,
but maybe one here,
but like there's a
whole area with nothing.
So this part of the,
this is going to be
in the internal capsule
basal ganglia area
that the lenticulostrite
arteries, uh,
um, provide blood
to, and, well, yeah,
basal ganglia, pitamen,
I don't know why
that, uh, I gotta
remove that currency,
uh, globus pallidus,
coniote nucleus,
uh, internal capsule,
common site, uh,
the lenticulostrite
arteries
are a common
site for small
strokes, those
are small vessels,
small territory, so, of
what's called lacunar
infarcts but you can
have a lot of lacunar
infarcts and it's in
a very critical area
of the internal capsule
and the basal ganglia
too and that region
lacks collateral a lot
of if any collateral
flow because they're
very small and they come
from deep penetrating
arteries okay so
they're susceptible to
watershed infarcts and
also this because there's
not a lot of collateral
flow okay one of
the characteristic
features of this region
though is if you get
ischemia you'll get pure
motor or sensory loss
okay so that might
be included with what
you're dealing with so
lipohylinosis and here's
the MRI that shows
lesion there's lacuna
infarcts and here's
this is good this is
throwing a atherosclerotic
plaque in comparison
with lipohylinosis.
What the hylin is
is when you look
under a microscope
or even just
grossly at the
thickened wall it looks
kind of pink orange
and homogeneous
glassy thickened wall.
There may be some
component of
atherosclerosis there too
because you can have
two things at once.
But that's due
to hypertension.
And that damaging
vessels and causing
extravization of plasma
proteins into the wall
of the vessel, causing
thickening of it.
Okay.
So, lipohyognosis
affects small arteries,
arteriosclerosis,
and arterioles. So,
that's arteriolosclerosis
associated with
hypertension and diabetes.
And that's associated
with these small
vessels, so
lenticulostriates, going
into the basal ganglia
and you get these
small lacunar infarcts.
That's not the only
place you can get
lacunar infarcts, but
that's a common place.
So the artery is
thick and narrow due
to, like I said, some
fat, but also this
glassy protonaceous
hyaline material.
It could lead to
a condition of
chronic hypertensive
vasculopathy where
you get that
lipohylenosis of many
small vessels and
get these lacunar
strokes of all of
this region here.
And lacunar is
named for the lake
-like effect when
you see it on an
imaging study.
This is a T2 MRI,
okay,
so hyper-intent
signal in the base
of ganglia caused
that ******.
It can be silent or
severe impairment,
it all depends
on the anatomical
location that
was affected.
And this is just a
reminder, this is where
the internal capsule
is, it's right
here, it has a posterior
part, posterior
limb, and an anterior
limb, anterior part of
the brain, posterior
part of the brain.
and that's where the
axon nerve fibers
are sent in a
fan-like pattern
from the cerebral
cortex down into
the spinal cord
into your body
and this is
called the corona
radiata below the
cerebral cortex
that's just a reminder
embolic strokes
that's 20% of
strokes caused by
embolus from somewhere
else in the body
there can be something
called an embolic
shower and
that's going to be
cardiogenic which means
the material is
going to be flowing
through the heart
well I don't
know why it's
cardiogenic there
think about removing
that I mean the
heart is moving it
but it often refers
to fat emboli
typically after a long
bone fracture like car
crash and orthopedic
surgery. And so
you get a lot of
these tiny flat back
globules and they
do pass through your
heart and lungs.
Alright.
So, often referring
to fat emboli.
Fat emboli syndrome
of blockages of
small vessels,
mostly in the lungs,
brain, and skin so
you can get petechia
with general
cerebral dysfunction.
Okay?
You know,
disorder of
consciousness,
often without
localizing signs
and it's characteristically
affecting
the white matter with
hemorrhagic lesions
of bone marrow emboli
it's called fat
emboli because there's
a lot of fat in bone
marrow if you ever
look at it so there's
a lot of fat in
there you'll see bone
marrow elements in
the embolus as well
cardiac causes most
common is atrial
fibrillation because
it's just sitting there
quivering and so blood
is going to become
still and begin to
clot and some of
those clots can travel
to different parts of
the body. After an
MI, maybe there'll
be a region of the
heart not functioning
properly, you could
get a thrombus there
which can have a
piece break off. Vowel
problems, prosthetic
bowels, some tumors,
inflammation, you can
get septic emboli,
which means you
get bacteria
and other debris
that travels as
an embolus from
septic focus.
Romantic disease
is an example of an
infection that
damages heart valves
and other structures
in the heart.
So now we're talking
about embolic
ischemic strokes of
something coming from
somewhere else in the
body and affecting
your brain. Okay so
it has to go through
this structure right
here, the aorta.
It can get there
by passing through
the lungs and there
are some things that
can pass through
the lungs um but
there's some odd
conditions where it
doesn't have to pass
through the lungs
uh if you have a a
pain uh cardiac septum
um from foreign middle
valley or something
else then if you
have a clock you know
coming from the venous
circulation okay like
a dbt or something
like that um and uh it
doesn't have to go
through the lungs or it
could be a big opening
right here so it
could travel right
over to the systemic
circulation up through
the aorta and cause a
****** that came from
the venous circulation,
DBT but that's a
paradoxical cerebral
embolus you wouldn't
expect that to happen
so central defects
can cause that
and I gave the
example of DBT
so non-cardiogenic,
non-thrombotic
cerebral or pulmonary
emboli examples
I already mentioned
fat embolism
and the reason I
mention the fat one is
because how do they
get from because
they come from the
venous circulation
right how do they come
from there and get
through the lungs
and go to the stem
because not everybody
has a septal defect
although more than
you would think too
so these globules
they're tiny and they
enter the arteries
after a fracture
and
the microglob
microscopic globules can
deform and pass into
the arterial or systemic
circulation by
bypassing the lung or
through arteriovenous
shunts, okay? So,
there'll be tiny
little microscopic
globules and then
they'll pass through
the lungs and
then maybe they'll
start associating
with each other and
start making bigger
globules, okay?
Okay.
amniotic fluid embolism
can occur and that
so that's where
amniotic fluid and some
debris like skin cells
and things like that
entered mom's
circulation and it's an
emergency medical
emergency there's a triad
that occurs with this
also with fat embolism
they can trigger
this kind of triad it
can cause respiratory
failure of PE is going
to happen and cause
focal neuro deficits
and in this case with
this embolism it can
trigger an anaphylactoid
like reaction by
releasing tissue
factor and other stuff
from this debris into
the mom circulation.
So you get neural
effects, lung effects
and then the pulmonary
vasoconstriction
that's also going to
be affecting the brain
and so you can end
up with heart failure
okay you know from
this pp hypotension and
hypoxemia okay so
that's your neuro effect
then it could trigger
DIC as well because
I mentioned tissue
factor already and
cause vascular spasms
so can cause vocal
ischemic strokes and
hemorrhages as well,
okay, because it
can activate the
complement cascade,
it can activate the
coagulation cascade,
okay, because of
the factors in the
skin cells and other
cells that are
forming these emboli.
And fat emboli
can trigger the
same sort of
phenomena as well,
but amniotic fluid
embolism can,
and produce what's
called disseminated
intravascular
coagulation.
So also, this
is just as a, by
the way, tumors
can break out
little pieces
and cause emboli.
Air, like from a
syringe, if you
don't get the air
out before you
inject, they can
produce air emboli
and have negative
consequences.
So here's an
example of the fat
embolism. This is
just a good diagram.
Here's a reconstruction
from a 3-D CT.
I wrote O again.
It's supposed
to be of the femur
shaft fracture,
which you can
see right there.
Okay.
Here, you rarely
see these fat emboli
on CTs. But here is
the iliac vein, and
it shows the fat
embolism right here.
Okay.
which you don't really
see that often, and
here would be the, I
guess it's the iliac,
okay, so it would
be the psoas
muscles, I
guess, intestine,
okay,
part of the pelvis,
I think, okay,
so yeah, I guess
that would be
one of the iliacs
right there,
okay, and you
can see there's
some blood, but
there's also,
where that yellow
asterisk is,
just like here a defect
and it appears dark
okay so the panembolism
is in the right
common iliac vein on
the axial plane of
abdominal oh I didn't
put the T in that should
be CT gosh I thought
I did proofread this
bunch time but okay
so I that level of
intensity is consistent
with fat and the asperage
showed 86 Hounsfield
units which is
consistent with fat so
that's why knowing a
few things about like
things like Hounsfield
units helps this is
that global ischemic
ischemia I was
talking about before
it causes strokes
in those watershed
regions and so these
colors show where
those watershed
regions are okay so
So those are between
the different
branches of the
internal carotid artery.
So the middle
cerebral, anterior
cerebral, watershed
area would be here,
posterior cerebral,
middle cerebral,
watershed area would be
here, and also some of
the deeper penetrating
arteries will have
watershed regions as
well and produce strokes
in those characteristic
regions and I
show them on these
different image images
let's see what this is a
flare MRI and I put
what that is over here
it suppresses bright
signals okay so it
makes you be able to
pick up blood a little
bit easier so this
happens if there's global
hyperperfusion it can
lead to infarcts in
these watershed zones,
okay, so between
the major blood vessel,
you know, branches.
Typically, deep brain
structures can be
affected, typically
between deep vascular
territories of the
MCA and ACA, okay,
so C here is an
internal watershed and
part between the
superficial and deep
perforators of the
middle cerebral artery.
So it's those deep
perforators, remember,
those are subject to
not penetrating deeply
enough and maybe just
supplying the bare
minimum of oxygen that
those cells needed to
function properly. But
now the blood pressure
drops super low and
now they're hypoxic.
Okay,
so A is showing
those watershed
regions, D here
is showing this,
okay, so that's blood,
so that's between
the anterior and
middle cerebral
arteries, okay, so
this region here and
also this region here,
anterior and middle
would come in, send
some perforating
branches to that area
right there that's
susceptible to a
watershed infarct.
This is what a global
ischemic ******
might look like.
Remember, cystic cavities.
There's something called
the insular ribbon
and I'll explain it.
Well, you can read it.
But I'll tell
you real quick.
So neurons, as you know,
very sensitive
to hypoxia.
But the most vulnerable
ones are going
to be the hippo,
the hippocampus,
CA1 region, neocortex,
these layers,
Purkinje cells in the
cerebellum,
watershed areas,
and deep locations
between artery
territories, like we
were just looking at.
And so there's
a mnemonic that
vulnerable hippostate
pure water.
Let's help you
remember that.
Okay,
so if it's mild,
there might just be a
little bit of
confusion and you might
recover with this
global ischemic ******.
However, it's
widespread neuron death,
but you survive.
There's a high
likelihood of persistent
vegetative state
at that point.
Okay.
So, here's an
example of an early
CET indicator of
acute ischemic
****** in the
MCA territory.
There's something
called the insular
cortex ribbon
or ribbon loss,
okay, and that's called
the insular ribbon
sign when there is
a loss, okay, so
on the left side here,
you have a question
mark because you don't
see what's called
the insular ribbon,
which is a clear
distinction between
the gray matter and
white matter in this
region on the insular
cortex, okay, you
do see, it's It's
kind of highlighted
with brighter here
and these arrows and
over here it's not,
but
you can see how
there's loss of the
distinction between
those, that's one of the
early signs. It's
vulnerable to hyperperfusion
and rapid edema
blurs the normal gray
and white matter boundary
okay on the right
side that's what it
normally would look
like except for the
highlighting that they
put there that's an
early indicator okay
TIA also known as a
mini ****** that's
in a schema kind of
attack and we already
had this picture here
so something could
come through here and
stop right there as
an embolic and causing
an embolic ******.
Mini ****** is a
transient ischemic attack.
Transient means it's
going to be brief, it's
reversible, and there's
going to be focal
effects. For example,
here it's affecting
one of the eyes. That's
non-convulsive and
ischemic neurologic
disturbance, usually up to
15 minutes. It can be
a little bit longer,
about 24 hours, and
it's still called a TIA.
But you can have
many of these,
but between
attacks, you may
show a normal
neurological exam.
This is going
to be associated
with cerebral
atherosclerosis, because
part of that
might break off.
And the condition called
amaurosis fugax,
which I already
explained, which
is transient.
But it is transient,
but it's often a warning
sign for a ****** or
permanent blindness,
because that was
just one shot.
Who's to say there's
not more coming?
So you should have a full
neurologic workout
for ******.
So clinical management
of ischemic ******.
It results in focal acute
neurologic symptoms,
such as this one
shown here by
this gentleman.
And they can
include sudden
headache, blurry
vision, dizziness,
slurred speed, confusion,
contralateral arm and
face pain, and here
I italicize face
grouping, and numbness.
so thrombolytic therapy
is contraindicated
in a brain hemorrhage
of any cause
what do you do if
it's going to be
you know a hemorrhagic
****** I know we were
talking about ischemic
but I put in hemorrhagic
because in this case
you probably want
to give thrombolytic
as quick as you can but
down here maybe not
what do you do well try
to control the blood
pressure reverse any
anticoagulants that could
possibly be on reduce
the brain spoiling
because that's going to
happen you don't want
to injure the brain
anymore than it already
is and repair whatever
underlying cause it
is and of the bleeding
and relieve pressure
okay on the brain and
the blood pressure you
know because that could
cause more hemorrhaging
okay okay here we
are with ischemic
****** though right so
remember time is tissue
loss okay so same thing
for hemorrhagic ******
too quick as you can
you know start treatments
but remember there's
an acronym for these
ischemic ****** do
they have a problem with
balance do they have
a problem seeing a
double vision face group
arm weakness speech
difficulty T is time to
call 911 that's the
be fast acronym if
suspect ****** because
time is tissue loss so
they could be losing a
CNS rapidly right now.
So this shows that
they need to get
identified through
a CT non-contrast
what kind of ******
they're having
and this is just
an example of a CT.
and here's you know
get them to definitive
therapy less than
four and a half
hours of system onset
so we make sure you
know the time of
this symptom started
so when those folks
arrive you can tell
them you know they
had symptoms one
hour ago so they know
you know they need
to get in the hospital
which they have.
So there's medicines
that can solve clots if
it's ischemic, not
hemorrhagic, or there
can be surgical removal
through thrombectomy.
Okay.
There's something
called ischemic ******
hemorrhagic
transformation, and that's
where a vessel near
the infarct is damaged
because because of
inflammation, you know,
there's necrosis,
neutrophils, all that.
And so there's
reperfusion, and
then hemorrhage
occurs because
of these damaged
blood vessels.
Or maybe there's
ischemia or reperfusion
injury from
thrombolytic therapy.
Okay.
So different kinds of
hemorrhagic infarct.
If it's just small
hemorrhages throughout
the brain as can
occur with something
that's called CAA,
which I'll go over
with you, then that
can produce no mass
effect. But if it's
a large parenchymal
hemorrhage, and that
usually is due to
more severe bleeding
with mass effect, it
could be potentially
life-threatening.
This is showing
petechiae scattered
around these lenticular
striped arteries.
So there's been
accumulation, because of
this hemorrhage, it
was converted from
ischemic to hemorrhagic
and it broke through
this side of the
ventricle. And now there's
blood in the ventricle.
So you can see
the petechiae, but
you can also see the
interventricular
hemorrhage and the brain's
midline shift. okay
so this would be the
right hemisphere that's
supposed to be around
the right side but
that's pushing the
left hemisphere over the
same and the ventricles
are being shifted
so so this is a
hemorrhaging infarct
type 2 that you see here
there's no significant
mass effect that
you can tell and this
is a a significant
parenchymal hematoma,
parenchymal hemorrhage
type 2, occupies
more than 30% of the
region, and you have
significant mass effect
and more significant
sequelae from that.
Hemorrhagic strokes
can be, okay,
hemorrhagic ******,
that's bleeding into the
brain from a ruptured
vessel. It can
be intracerebral,
ICH or subarachnoid,
ICH most commonly
associated with hypertension
as intracerebral
and or cerebral
amyloid angiopathy,
also known as CAA.
Subarachnoid is bleeding
in the space around
the brain, commonly
caused by ruptured
aneurysm, head trauma
or an AVM, that's
more common in men and
increases with age.
I just want to mention
EDH, epidural and
subdural are types of
intracranial bleeding,
but they're not,
and can cause ******
-like symptoms, but
they're not causes,
they're not
types of strokes.
Okay, they're not
hemorrhage strokes
or anything
like that, they
don't come from a
cerebral vessel.
But it's often
misdiagnosed a
****** because
they mimic, okay.
So here's some
pathophysiology.
So the most common
incidence, about
60 years, hemorrhagic
and parched
parallels ischemic with
blood, extravasation
and resorption
being added on top.
The vessel ruptures,
hypertension, CAA,
trauma, aneurysm,
blood extravasates,
you get a mass effect
and so as blood
extravasates from there
you'll get swelling
and that's what
the asterisk shows.
Let's see, where's
the white arrow?
Yeah, that's edema
in that region.
Okay,
so that tissue
swelling and everything
is going to start
compressing adjacent
tissues, as well
as the hematoma.
Okay,
what you see
on the head, CT
is bright, and
it's flare MRI.
This is a dark region.
And then the edema
is going to be
the white asterisk
on this flare MRI.
So, the hematoma
is going to
press surrounding
structures and
elevate intracranial
pressure.
There
is some toxic effects
of blood products as
well because reactive
oxygen species are
released and that does
cause inflammation and
damaging of surrounding
cells and tissues.
So, that needs to
be managed, the
inflammation of
the brain because
that's going to
cause edema as well.
So, chronic hypertension
is going to be most
associated with
intracerebral hemorrhage.
And rather than the
cerebral hemispheres
or lobes, like frontal
and all that, it's
going to be more deep
structures, okay?
Like those
small arteries,
the lenticular stride
arteries you talked
about that are supplying
the basal ganglia, so
it's going to be
commonly occurring there.
If it's long-standing
hypertension, it could
cause outpouching of
those vessels. Thin
-walled balloons that
develop over time, those
are called Charcot
-Bouchard microaneurysms.
Okay.
And this is a
cerebral amyloid
angiopathy caused by
amyloid beta and the
tunic amenia
adivaticia of cortical
vessels, but also
in the Maniches.
It causes vascular
fragility.
The system has a
normal, a normal
tensive elderly
person that has low
bar, because
remember there was
that senile amyloid
that does occur,
A normal tensive
elderly person that has
low-bar intracerebral
hemorrhage, okay,
versus non-low-bar
that we just mentioned.
So CAA increases
with age.
You can have
recurrent hemorrhages
due to this CAA,
and it's associated
with a gene encoding
apolipoprotein E,
okay? And here's an
example that's more
cortical than in the
basal ganglia region.
So here's intracerebral
hemorrhage.
You can see how the
CAA, the beta amyloid,
weakens the vessel
wall, and there's
perivascular
hemorrhages that you
can see in these
regions. And these are
going to be these
tiny pockets that
are picked up on
what's called SWI MRI.
And that's just a special
procedure that
allows you to see
these hemorrhages
more clearly.
So you can see it's an
inflammatory response,
It's damaging the
vessels, the aneloid
is damaging the vessels
itself, but also the
inflammation is, and
so we get bleeding.
Subarachnoid
hemorrhage, okay,
is blood in the
subarachnoid space.
And you can see
that on your CT,
and here's an
example of that.
Here's what would
be a normal. You
see it's dark here,
it's not, okay.
Most commonly
from trauma,
then ruptured aneurysms,
also known as very
aneurysms. They
present with sudden
severe thunderclap
headache. The
patient may even say,
it's the worst
headache of my life.
Next to stiffness,
photophobia,
and rapidly lose
consciousness.
And so here's a
starburst pattern of
probable ruptured very
aneurysm, because this
is in the subarachnoid
space, location of
where most of the
very aneurysms are
located which is circle
which is in subarachnoid
space okay trauma
commonly produces
socal subarachnoid
hemorrhage so like when
you hit your head so
in the sulci vessels
on the surface may
bleed into the sulci
okay it's the most
common overall cause
So blood in the
sulci because tears
small arteries traveling
into that space.
Often occur in a bony
region like the skull
base because it's
really irregular
there. So if the brain
scrapes along that,
you may get some
tearing of those small
vessels and bleeding
in subarachnoid space.
Spontaneous hemorrhages.
Most common
spontaneous one is
going to be due to
an aneurysm. and
this is where
they mostly occur,
okay, in the circle
of willis, but within
the circle of
willis, the anterior
communicating artery is
the most frequent, okay.
So, he's also called
saccular or bari.
The majority, circle
of willis, but there
are some risk
factors, like otters,
domos, those collagen
disorders, and marfans,
being female, smoking,
family history,
polycystic kidney
disease, the autodomal
dominant type, is also
associated with very
aneurysms so this is
just about the size they
can rupture any time you
have acute increasing
cranial pressure
like straining on the
stool or possibly even
****** ****** 50% of
patients die after
the first rupture but
survivors often improve
and recover in minutes
but repeat bleeding
can be common and it's
worse prognosis each
time it does blazed.
So this is how they
would be treated
and I just gave an
image to show you.
If it's a fusiform
kind of aneurysm, it's
just kind of becoming
dilated in that region.
A stent can be used
to bridge that vessel.
Or if this is like
an outpouching of the
side of the vessel and
that becomes involved,
you can put this
coiled material that
causes clotting in that
region and that could
close that off or you
could clip that okay
so blood doesn't flow
in there anymore.
Arteriovenous malformation
so there should
be capillaries between
the arteries and
the veins but sometimes
it's malformed in
some individuals and
it can affect the CNS.
One way it does affect
is these are arteries
going directly into
veins, no capillaries
in between. So it's high
flow, a lot of blood
flows through here
and so the surrounding
tissue is not going
to get as much. But if
there's hemorrhage or
clot forms then that
will cause that territory
to have ischemia.
Okay, let's see.
These are usually
congenital and enlarge
with age and often
progress from low flow
juvenile to high flow
high pressure adult
types okay so you'll see
it in adults more then
you see it more in
adulthood and grossly
if you look at it it
just looks like tangle
of vessels of blood
vessels and here's an
example of one this
one's really big okay
and this is just some
kind of window they
use just to kind of
look at this spot right
here there's kind of
blocking this part
off affects males more
often often presents
up to 30 10 to 30 years
of age as a seizure
disorder of the ABM,
but you can have an
inner cerebral hemorrhage
or subarachnoid.
Most commonly, the
middle meningeal
artery territory is
going to be affected.
Management of
one that's not
ruptured yet is surgical,
and then here's
a grade to
help with
surgical planning.
You don't memorize that.
Trauma. Physical
forces may cause skull
fractures, you can
get parenchymal
and muscular injury.
Here are just many
different ways you
can get injuries
that are shown in
this cartoon diagram.
So following types
of forces we're
going to go over
a little bit,
not so much
penetrating, but blunt,
acceleration,
deceleration,
open or closed injury
refers to if there's
skin over the surface
or if the fractured
components are open to
the environment, okay?
multiple
etiologies, you can
fall, you can
get shot, you can
get me in a car
that crashes.
Head injury from
trauma is a leading
cause of death
for ages 15 to 40
years in the United
States of America.
And it's a major cause
of permanent disability.
It's the most
common cause
of pediatric
traumatic death.
So this is the depressed
type of skull fracture.
It The bone descends
more than the thickness
of the bone that it
was connected to.
So this is the depressed
skull fracture.
Surgery is considered
on these fractures
with deficits
that are going to
be referable. Once
again, it's the
anatomic region that's
going to determine
what kind of
deficits you have.
Okay,
so this is showing
a depressed skull
fracture, the white
arrow shows soft tissue
swelling, and this
is how the repair
is done with these
plates and screws,
put these pieces
back together.
This is showing
diastatic fracture
where the suture
comes apart.
B is going to be your
depressed fracture,
linear fracture shown
here in a bad area of
middle minute shields
there and this is
going to be a basilar
fracture which is bad.
Basilar fracture
will show raccoon
eyes and battle
sign which is blood,
okay, well bruising
which is blood.
This is basilar skull
fracture typically
seen on the oval
roof so that's
why you might see
this pretty readily.
It's ecumosis behind
the ear, mastoid
process, raccoon's eyes,
blood from the skull
fracture seeps into
soft tissues okay and
so you can also see CSF
leakage from the nose
or ear rhinorrhoea
and that could be a
sign of basilar skull
fracture or meningitis
may fall once again
that could be a sign
if you don't have any
obvious signs could
be a basilar skull
fracture and here is
skull fracture involving
the foramen magnum.
Traumatic brain injury is
two distinct processes.
You got the primary
brain injury where you
get a cortical
contusion. Contusion is
just bleeding into that
tissue. You can get
lacerations. You get
bone fragments in
there. You get something
called diffuse axonal
injury. You can get
brain stem contusion
which is bad because
the brain stem.
Secondary injury, so
after the initial one,
you can get intracranial
hematomas, edema,
ischemia.
All these are
kind of due to
elevated intracranial
pressure or shock.
There can be
basal spasm too.
Concussion is a functional
manifestation of
mild traumatic brain
injury. I give a little
bit about concussion
down here. It's a
functional brain syndrome
that typically affects
memory and orientation
and may involve loss
of consciousness,
but not always. It's
typically immediate,
transient, a brief period
of amnesia, following
a force to the body.
Recovery is usually
complete, it's based
on signs and symptoms,
I list some here.
It's functional
manifestation, but no trauma
-related intracranial
abnormalities seen.
If this does happen,
then it causes this
metabolic problem in
the brain where it's
more sensitive to
stress or injury until
it's fully recovered.
So it has to be a
period where the
brain recovers because
it's more sensitive.
The next injury
might be more severe.
Coup contra, coup
injury, okay,
so this is where
you get an injury
on the exact
opposite side from
being, from one
blow to your head.
So at the contusion
point, you will have
a point of contact
coup injury, so
this is showing your
coup injury in this
case, on the CT, I
mean MRI, CT, sorry.
coup injury at the point
of injury and contra
-coup damage of the
brain force a brain
opposite and this is
kind of showing how that
would occur so you get
your coup injury here
hit and then the brain
is pushed over to this
side you know from
that that force that
impacted the head and
the brain from here where
it was hit, hits the
other side of the
skull because it's a closed
structure, and that's
where you get your
contraceptive injury.
Direct parenchymal injury
is a bruise or contusion.
Well, it could be
laceration and severe
cerebral hemorrhage,
I wouldn't call that
a bruise, but if
it's an impact with
hemorrhages within a
region, a localized
region, then that
can be considered a
contusion or a bruise,
and that's going to be
caused by blood trauma.
It's usually red
-shaped, red-shaped,
rod-based along the
surface, and it's
transmitted through
the skull and causing
rapid displacement.
Manifestations could
be concussion or, what
I was saying, contusions
and lacerations.
There are
neuropsychiatric
syndromes that can occur.
Chronic traumatic
encephalopathy was called
dementia pugilistica
in the past, and
that's an illness after
repeated head trauma,
for example in
boxers or I think in
people who play football
or soccer might have
a similar effect with
long-term playing.
So let's just give
an example, you get
tau neurofibrillary
tangles in the gyri,
but that's with
direct parenchymal
injury from
repeated trauma.
Diffuse axonal injury
is something that might
develop after traumatic
brain injury and
that's damage of deep
white matter regions.
What you get is some
sort of traumatic
injury that's going to
cause stretching and
shearing forces
and that's going to
injure the axons, you
know, the extensions
from the neurons. So
the neurons are not
going to be functioning
properly anymore.
So what you'll see is
axonal swelling and
focal hemorrhages and
degeneration of the
fiber as artifacts
so you can see it in
these region here okay
so these are white
matter based lesions
you know loss of those
structures and the
image shows particular
hemorrhages in these
white matter tracks
okay so those axons
aren't functioning anymore
and there's hemorrhage
in that region.
So high-speed
brain injury may
do that. For
example, blast
injury or motor
vehicle crash.
Even in the absence
of physical impacts on
the skull, you get
cerebral edema and
increased intracranial
pressure. Cardiac mortality
is high, up to 50%.
So the SWI, once
again, is really good at
picking up hemorrhages
which are known as
microbleeds from this
axonal damage and
you can see that in
these regions right here
this one doesn't look
so micro these ones
look more small these
ones are bigger but
it's picked up on SWI
those are those dark
dark spots representing
hemocytral deposits of
old small hemorrhages
epidural hematoma
is located between
the skull and the
dura And it's going to
look like a lens.
And it's going to be
biconcave, lentiform
-shaped extra-axial fluid.
And that's going to
be the characteristic.
Okay?
And it's commonly
due to a fracture
just over the middle
meningeal artery.
And then it's going to
involve laceration of
that and arterial
blood going into that
space. so you get that
lenticular pattern so
it's going to present
as a loose interval then
rapid deterioration
uh you're going to get
headache vomiting lost
consciousness so you're
going to need prompt
diagnosis and surgery
to drain that because
brain herniation
becomes a risk in this
situation so it's an
emergency so craniotomy
would need to be done
there's a bone flap and
there's the hole and
then there's hematoma
ready to be evacuated.
So it's almost always
evolving a
skull fracture.
Subdural hemorrhage
is between the
dura and the arachnoid
matter. So it
involves tearing
and bridging veins.
So it's low pressure,
often, low
pressure blood.
Often it's going to
be elderly because
the brain shrinks a
little bit so those
veins are under a
little bit of tension,
and they're stretched
a little bit.
Chronic alcoholics,
so brain atrophy.
So minor traumas
can cause
chronic subdural
hemorrhages.
And these ones are
going to be crescent
-shaped, okay, on
their CT scans. And
that's going to be an
acute subdural. What
you see here is sub
-falcine herniation,
because here's a
false form ligament.
and this is pushing
the right side
cerebral brain structures
over to the left.
Okay,
so you get a shift of
midline and compression.
It's usually self
-limited and the hematoma
is usually broken
down and organized
and usually Usually
there's progressive
neurological
deterioration which is
typical but if you
get care you recover.
Shaken baby syndrome
is child *****,
can't shake babies
because their neck
muscles can't keep
their head from those
very violent forces
on their brain.
What you see here
is an acute subdural
hemorrhage on the
right frontal temporal
bone, and you see
starting to see
this midline shift
that's developing,
and this is kind
of crescent-shaped,
to describe the subdural.
So the brain
bangs against the
skull, tearing the
bridging veins.
So you get
lethargy, seizures,
retinal
hemorrhages in 80%.
So that's why
in case of child
***** where it
could be death,
retinal hemorrhage
is something
that you always look for.
You can also
have a history of
many fractures.
So you look at the
medical record,
you might find that
they have a
clavicle fracture,
radius fracture, all
kinds of fractures.
interventricular
hemorrhage you can see that
this blood which is
bright is within these
lateral ventricles so
it's in the ventricular
system and that
can result from an
intracerebral hemorrhage
or trauma or preterm
inference germinal
matrix which is primitive
cells just below
the surface of the
ventricles that helps
produce neurons and
they're it's a highly
vascular layer in the
brain and it can and
because that region it's
a preterm infants it's
not fully developed
and successful to
injury may bleed and if
clots, you can
cause hydrocephalus.
Brain herniations.
So,
falsiform ligament. So
if you get some mass
effect that pushes
the brain over this
way, then that's sub
-falsiform herniation.
And if that mass effect
pushes this part of
the cortex down below
the tentorium cerebelli,
then that's going to
be transtentorial.
If it pushes
down through the
foramen magnum,
but this is
part of the
cerebellar tonsil,
then you see that
below the foramen
magnum, that's a
tonsillar herniation.
Right here you
see that on a CT,
midline shift and
herniation below the
falso, this is a
subfalcine herniation.
So, something inside
is producing pressure
and pushing the brain,
often from brain
swelling or bleeding,
so it can be a ******
or tumor, and I went
over these types.
This isn't
really indicating
it, but the most
common type is
going to be the
subphalcine.
I guess I should have put
it with that
material there,
and it's describing
this image. The sub
-fowl scene is also
called cingulate because
the cingulate gyrus
is what goes beneath.
Below the falk
cerebrite, you get that
midline shift, and it's
the most common type.
Symptoms, it can
cause headache due
to increased ICP,
contralateral leg
weakness, it sets
the region on the,
what's that called,
the homunculus?
You know, that
image of, you know,
the motor sensory
regions supplied by
the cerebral cortex,
That's the motor
region on the brain.
And that's the
region that the
legs would supply.
Okay.
Transtentorial
herniation. Okay.
So below the
tentorium cerebelli,
there are some
structures down there,
including these
oculomotor nerves.
Okay. And that can
produce what is called
a blown pupil. So
you need an immediate
intervention because
you know you're
herniating right now.
So what does that mean?
So this pupil bright
light should be a
little bit constricted.
This pupil is
very large in bright
light if you want to
make sure you can
use your pin light.
So you got a
very large pupil
that doesn't
react at all when
you shine bright
light in it.
That's a long pupil.
So it needs immediate
neurosurgical
intervention to
evacuate that
hematoma and relieve
the pressure.
transporaminal tonsillar
herniation okay
so this is looking
a little bit like a
Chiari malformation
to me but it could be
because there's some
increase in pressure
somewhere maybe there's
cerebral edema so you
get compression of the
brainstem and medulla
oblongata you can see
the medulla oblongata
would be here. Here's
the brain stem.
Disrupting vitals
functions such as
respiration and
cardiovascular system.
It's a neurosurgical
emergency,
has a very
poor prognosis.
And this is the
summary of these
different types.
The histology,
ischemic hemorrhagic,
traumatic fractures,
trauma, and thank
you. Here's the link
for the feedback
form, and please fill
it out and let me
know what you think.
I think I probably went
a few minutes over, okay,
sorry,
I'll do better,
okay, thanks for
your time, good luck
with your studies,
send me emails,
calls, or come see
me if you want.
Okay, have a
good day, bye.